لقد مرت سنة على حياتك في المملكة
العربية السعودية، أين تعتقد أن المستوى
الآن هو المستوى الحالي
لأكون صادقًا، أعتقد أن هذا
الدوري السعودي ليس أسوأ من
دوري FRS ليكون في رأيي في Fr League
I  أعتقد أنه لديك فريقان
يتمتعان بمستوى جيد في السعودية الآن
وأعتقد أن الأمر أكثر تنافسية حيث يمكنهم
قول ما يريدون، هذا مجرد
رأيي وأنا ألعب لمدة عام واحد لذلك
أعرف ما أتحدث عنه ولكن أعتقد
في الوقت الحالي، نحن أفضل من
دوري الأصدقاء، لذلك لا نزال
نحسن ما هو المفتاح في رأيك فيما
يتعلق بالارتقاء إلى المستوى التالي،
والمفتاح هو هل لديك العديد من العوامل التي
تنطبق على تحسين الدوري كما قلت
من قبل، لديهم الكثير  الأمور يجب أن
تتحسن ولكن أعتقد أنه مع
الأشخاص الأقوياء أه خلفهم للمساعدة في تغيير
ثقافة كرة القدم قليلاً
والعادات السيئة أه أعتقد أننا
سنصل إلى نقطة واحدة وهي أن الناس هناك
في السعودية سيكونون فخورين بالاستثمار
هناك  إنه أمر ضخم، فلماذا لا نؤمن بذلك
كما هو الحال في السعودية حتى في دبي،
فالأشياء تتغير والعالم يتغير لذا فهم
يستحقون الفرصة، كم
استخدمت النقد
كحافز، قل مرة أخرى كم
استخدمت النقد كحافز عندما تكون
جزءًا منه  من الرحلة التي أحبها عندما
يشكك الناس بي وأثبت مرة أخرى
أنه في عام واحد مع النجاح، كانت
الرحلة صعبة بعض الشيء في العام الماضي ولكني سعيد بحدوث تلك الأشياء
لأنها تجعلني أشعر بمزيد من
القوة ويمكنك ذلك  انظر هذا العام لقد قمت
بموسم رائع آه كنت أفضل هداف
تخيل التغلب على تلك الحيوانات
مثل يانج ليونز مثل آلاند على سبيل
المثال آه بالأهداف لذلك أنا فخور بأنني
سأبلغ 39 عامًا قريبًا وما زلت أبدو جيدًا
لذا  أنا
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
فخور إلى أي مدى يمكنك الاستمرار في هذا
المستوى،
لا أعرف، أنا أعيش يومًا بعد يوم، ما
مدى اعتمادك على البيانات
والحقائق ومدى غريزتك،
استمع
أنا"  لدي بعض المشكلات الشخصية والمهنية التي أواجهها
تجعلني أشعر وتجعلني
أفكر
بطريقة مختلفة كما أخبرتك من قبل أفكر في
الحاضر وفي اللحظة التي تكون فيها اللحظة
جيدة أشعر أنني بحالة جيدة وما زلت قادرًا على القيام
بذلك بعض الأهداف للمساعدة  فريقي سيساعد
المنتخب الوطني أيضًا لذا سأستمر في
اللحظة التي أنتهي فيها، لا أعرف
لأكون صادقًا ولكن بالطبع أه سيكون قريبًا قريبًا أعني
10 سنوات أخرى ولكني
أمزح، الأمر نسبي جدًا، إنه كذلك
قريب لا أعرف
دعونا نرى